please welcome back friend of the show
and host of food network's girl meets
farm
the award-winning blogger author of
molly on the range
molly yay drew
happy meat week oh molly i'm so
excited these are some of the best if
not the best meatless meatballs i've
ever had so i'm so excited for you to
teach us how to do it
well we have my ex-boyfriend's mom to
thank for them because
the title of the recipe in my book is
spaghetti and my ex-boyfriend's
meatless balls they were so good that
after i
broke up with him i had to go back and
get the recipe
and you know as someone who eats meat i
eat meat
they taste like meat and they are so
easy to make what i really love about
them
is the fact that they use such simple
ingredients ingredients you probably
already have
and you just throw everything into the
food processor so
are you ready to make these balls i love
these balls let's do this okay
so the ingredients we have in our food
processor they're essentially just
nuts and cheese so with the wall i'm
using walnuts but you can also use
almonds
it's important to toast them because it
makes them crunchier and brings out
their flavor
we've got parmesan cheese some garlic
parsley
and then a little bit of salt and now
drew so the recipe calls for
bread crumbs but when you made these on
your instagram you sub them for ritz
crackers
which i thought was the most genius
thing in the world
so i'm using ritz crackers and it's
gonna
hold them all together it's gonna find
them and the roots are gonna add so much
flavor i love it
so let's pulse everything together and
i like to keep a crunchier texture
so don't over blend it leave some bigger
bits
you can already start to smell it you
smell the garlic
i most certainly do and i have to say i
think the walnut as a meat substitution
is one of the most satisfying
they are meaty they're a meaty nut
they're really good
um and this recipe you can also
change up the jesus change up the spices
i like to do
sort of a middle eastern vibe and use
feta and some mint and cilantro
or you could also add fennel and crumble
the sausage onto pizza
meatless sausage yeah okay so we've got
our eggs in here and the eggs bind it
together
and this is it we're just gonna pulse
this to incorporate the eggs now
i have to say this was one of the most
pleasurable
easy recipes to make it was
pure joy i had pure joy
watching videos you know it made me so
happy well we should thank your ex
boyfriend
thank you eric okay we've got our
mixture here
by the way i have a few people i could
introduce him to
you i saw you interview tom green
and you are so nice to your
ex-boyfriends i'm so impressed i could
never
do that i you know i i i really do have
a good thank you for
saying that i uh tom especially
beautiful interview
thank you are you ready to roll these
balls
the key to these balls is you don't want
to pack them too
firmly because then you'll get a dense
texture so
just roll them loose enough so that they
hold together
and then we're going to put them into
some hot oil
and you can pan fry these you can also
deep fry them too because
no one said these had to be healthy and
so i have some oil here
these cook for a few minutes on all
sides just until they're golden
and then you plop them into red sauce
and you can serve them
on a slider you can serve them on a
hoagie
you can put them out at a party with
some toothpicks and then you have a fun
appetizer and you can see
who notices that they're fake meat
but of course today we're gonna go the
classic route
and spoon them over some spaghetti oh
yeah i'm spooning them right now
right on i think that um
just visuals and psychology is so
effective as i like over
serve myself um and
i think that the look of these meatballs
molly they just look so real and
authentic
and they taste so satisfying
that to me you're not only not
missing meat i think you're getting
something so much more
i mean this really is one of my favorite
dishes it's just
incredible beautiful it looks so good
i mean molly
what is it that it tastes like meat
they're kids like me
they're just like me and they're so easy
they're so easy
i mean it's i i'm not kidding to anyone
who may be kind enough to be watching
they taste
exactly like the best meatball
i don't think you would actually know
that they're not meatballs
and the ritz crackers in here just bring
them to a whole new level
i'm obsessed it's just perturbing
that you can have something that tastes
this much like meat
it's just so satisfying molly you're
such a genius
you know every once in a while when you
have like a vegetarian or a vegan thing
you're like
there's let's face facts this is not the
real thing
this i want you to eat next to a real
meatball and try to tell the difference
it's that extraordinary
do the taste test challenge do the pepsi
challenge on molly's
meatless meatballs oh molly i can't wait
to spend
more time with you i love you so much
this was so much fun
thank you go to thedrewberrymoreshow.com
for the full recipe
and it's going to blow your doors off
[Music]